[Music]
today's polls are incredibly lightweight
yet strong enough to absorb the vaulters
energy then throw it back to propel them
over the bar some polls are made of
carbon fiber others out of this material
resin impregnated fiberglass the first
step is to spread out the material and
cut out the pole pattern meanwhile a
slitter machine cuts the same material
into strips of a specific width then it
winds each strip into its own role
this spiral wrap machine automatically
unravels the strip and wraps it around a
hollow steel tube called a mandrel this
first layer of fiberglass gives the pole
its flexibility they wrap a second layer
in the opposite direction
[Music]
for the next players they remove the
mandrel and lay it on a table now it's
time for those fiberglass patterns they
cut earlier they heap the edge of the
first one with an iron melting the resin
in the fiberglass until it's tacky they
stick this edge to the mandrel then
slide the other end between heated
rollers the rollers wrap the rest of the
material around the mandrel to heat
activating the resin in the process
the mandrill and its multi-layer
fibreglass coat now go into an oven the
heat generated by steam starts at 175
degrees Fahrenheit this liquefies the
resin so that it resets the fiberglass
then the temperature gradually rises to
nearly 300 degrees solidifying the resin
again curing it and when it finishes a
pol extractor slides the mandrel out of
us now a fiberglass pole
[Music]
the pole moves on to a flex machine and
heart this is a stress test if there's
any type of defect the pole will crack
or break
but the flexor also permanently puts a
specific degree of curve in the pole
which helps the athlete ball fire
[Music]
now they make what's called the soft
side mark this helps the pole-vaulter
locate the bend in order to know where
to grip the pole
[Music]
next they apply a maximum weight label
indicating how heavy the vaulter can be
to finish the surface now they mount the
pole on a spindle then run a polishing
pad over it then using the solvent they
clean off the debris
[Music]
now that the surface is pristine they
wrap it in thin lightweight tape
different color tapes designate
different pole styles
[Music]
they cap the top of the pole with
plastic then at the bottom mount on a
molded tip made of hard rubber the
finishing touch is the manufacturers
decal
[Music]
vaulting poles come in various lengths
between 10 and 16 feet a pole design for
a heavier vaulter has to be stiffer than
one design for a lighter vaulter because
the pole has to propel more weight with
the same degree of bending
you